dismissed it but he was right there this
will be an interesting chess match here
right now the door was open for LA the
Sixers lead by eight Simmons
trying to toss it to him BD was held Oh
Paul George gets in there the officials
do as well they exchanged words and
embiid is now walking away I know this
about Marcus Morris in these situations
I've seen it he is not going to take a
step backwards not even half a step
backwards in these situations he's
saying come on
they got interlocked a shell from embiid
a two-handed push from Morris
the Philly fans but Marcus Morris is one
of theirs too the toughness is
appreciated here in this building Marcus
Morris the Philadelphia native and
JoEllen beat who knows how to get a
crowd energized by engaging with them
this just went a little extra and Morris
is nodding as if yeah come on the
officials will take a look
yeah there's certainly nothing there on
JoEllen beats part I don't know what
they'll do with Marcus Morris for the
for the two-handed shove I just like
this game tonight on
I like that two teams are going at it
that there's emotion in the game you
know a lot of times leading up to the
all-star break as you've seen teams can
sort of be checked out but no here
tonight these teams have battled had a
little bit of a playoff atmosphere
JoEllen beads been aggressive all night
fun to watch you go double technicals
here and beat with the shove and then
the two-handed push from Morris this is
the final game before the all-star break
for Philadelphia the Clippers will be in
Boston on Thursday night we'll have that
broadcast for you here on TNT and that's
another great game coming up it and look
for the Clippers to be in these
situations on the road against good
teams with George and Leonard playing
one of their rare games together however
this game ends up these are the kind of
games they need to play in to get ready
for the playoffs and likewise for Philly
though their challenges are more not in
this building but elsewhere it has just
been on a loop on the big screen so both
players have been staring at the monitor
above center court
multiple angles and it is indeed double
technicals Joelle and bead Marcus Morris
[Applause]
and indeed is heading to the free-throw
line room over there was a foul called
initially yes with JoEllen beat on the
duck e'en against the smaller Marcus
Morris and they fouled him trying to
make the catch
Brett Brown going right at that mismatch